بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم وعلى بركه الله
افتتاح الدوره الثانيه والثلاثون لمجلس
جامعه الدول العربيه على مستوى القمه
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو والامين
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه
الحضور الكرام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته يسرني ارحب بكم في بلدكم الثاني
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ونرحب بضيف
القمه فخامه
رئيس اوكرانيا ونامل ان تتكلم جهودنا
بالتوفيق والنجاح كما يسرني ان اشكر فخامه
الرئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه
الشعبيه عبد المجيد تبون على الجهود
المبذوله خلال تراس بلاده للدوره السابقه
ونشكر معالي الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه وجميع العاملين فيها على مبادر من
جهود لخدمه العمل العربي المشترك
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم نؤكد لدول
الجوار والاصدقاء في الغرب والشرق للسلام
والخير والتعاون والبناء بما يحقق مصالح
شعوبنا ويصون حقوق امتنا واننا لن نسمح
منطقتنا ميدان الصراعات ويكفينا طي صفحة
الماضي
تذكر سنوات مؤلمه من الصراعات عاشتها
المنطقه وعارت منها شعوبها وتعثرت بسببها
مسيره التنميه
اليوم حضور فخامه الرئيس بشار الاسد لهذه
القمه وصدور قرار جامعه الدول العربيه
بشان استئناف مشاركه وفود الحكومه السوريه
في اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه
ونامل ان يسهم ذلك في دعم استقرار سوريا
وعوده الامور لطبيعتها واستئناف دورها
الطبيعي في الوطن العربي بما يحقق الخير
لشعبها وما يدعم تطلعاتنا جميعا نحو
المستقبل افضل لمنطقتنا الحضور الكرام من
القضيه الفلسطينيه كانت ولا زالت هي قضيه
العرب والمسلمين المحوريه
وفقا لقرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره
السلام العربيه وغيرها من المرجعيات
الدوليه المتفق عليها بما يحقق مطلعات
الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق
انشقاق في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يكرسون جهودهم في دعم القضايا العربيه كما
نعمل على مساعده اطراف اليمنيه للوصول الى
حل سياسي شامل ينهي الازمه اليمني وفيما
يخص السودان نامل ان تكون لغه الحوار هي
الاساس لحفظ على وحده السودان وامن شعبهم
المخدراته وفي هذا الصدد
ترحب بتوقيع طرفين نزاع على اعلان جده
الالتزام بحمايه مدنيين وتسهيل العمل
الانساني ونامل التركيز خلال هذه
المحادثات على وقف فعال لاطلاق النار
تواصل مملكه بالتعاون مع الاشقاء
والاصدقاء والمجتمع الدولي
بذل الجهود الانسانيه وتفعيل قنوات
الاغاثه للشعب السوداني الشقيق ويطيب لنا
ان ننتهز هذه الفرصه بوجود فخامه الرئيس
ايلينسكي رئيس اوكرانيا ومشاركه هذه القمه
بالتاكيد موقف المملكه الداعم لكل ما يسهم
في خفض حده الازمه في اوكرانيا وعدم تدهور
الاوضاع الانسانيه واستعاده المملكه
واستعداد المملكه الاستمرار في بدل الجهود
الوساطه بين روسيا الاتحاديه واوكرانيا
ودعم جميع الجهود الدوليه الراميه الى حل
الازمه سياسيا بما يرسم في تحقيق الامن
والسلم الحضور الكرام ان وطننا العربي
يملك من المقومات الحضريه والثقافيه
والموارد البشريه والطبيعيه ما يؤهل لتبلغ
مكانه متقدمه وقياديه وتحقيق نهضه شامله
لدولنا في جميع المجالات والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات